Well, so some reason, man, some action scenes, like neon,
impossible to figure out what the is going on in Monga. Like I'm, I'm,
I'm looking at these panels and the going on. And I'm like,
I would need to like, get my,
my pen and draw along to like try and figure out what the actual cardiography
is.
[Inaudible] I would have more time.
It's having like a battlefield view and you showing me like,
like little statues move. Right.
So fans trying to figure out King Crimson for the animator.
That was literally me. I was like, what's going on.
At manga? I'm like, I will sit there for a good,
like 30 seconds staring at this light. Yeah. I have no idea.
That's the problem I have with like judge early on. Cause I was I'm reading it.
I'm like these stand pals,
like getting so weird that I'm looking at something and I'm like,
I guess the stand is doing its power, but I don't know what the was you doing?
Which is odd because then an action in Mongo, I started like,
not really care about cause half the time you can barely tell what's actually
happened. And you're just like putting the dots. I don't know.
There's something about watching the fight unfold and like the way it was meant
to in like a timed way with music and noise was so much more sad.
I, I dunno.
Cause I feel like that is the problem with a lot of anime fights period, right?
Is that they don't actually feel like fights. They feel like just,
they feel like impacts intermittently, uh, with,
with dialogue, with the twist, you know what I mean?
Cause like no one knows you see someone on my flights and you think no one
actually fights like this. You know what I mean? No one stories,
a punch says a sentence, then throws a punch back. You know what I mean?
Not that that's not how fights work. Literally every Bucky fight. Exactly.
Right. What's a fight without a dialogue. Come on gone.
Cause like that's why for example,
the fights in God of high school really stood out to me because they actually
felt like a Marshall last fight. You know what I mean?
Let's say what you want about the story or the whatever,
but the way the fights were directed and frames and just Cory choreographed,
they felt like actual fights. It felt like it felt like a Jackie Chan fight.
Right? Exactly. And I'm cause that's what,
that's what immediately stood out to me about that direction.
And that animation was that, you know,
sometimes you get like the NAR narrative episode where you have like,
you have like the basic normal narrative fights.
And then you have like this one episode that is just like this,
the studio puts in all their budget and they're a team on one fight.
And then that you, that, that is the fight that people remember.
You know what I mean? But most anime flights are just there. I mean,
they are literally just animated Monga panels and you can't tell what's going on
in a manga panel with action most of the time.
So that's really what sets the good flights from the.
Sometime I need that dialogue right. To help build it up. It's like a,
it's like a good poem, right? Sometimes you need the story to make the word.
Well, of course by, you know, I think there's like a limit to how much dialogue,
like, you know,
that's one thing I didn't like about like a lot of our tow fights is the fact
that it's like, I don't need a flashback in the middle of a pie. I like,
I need that. I like it when.
They're like internalizing their thoughts on the battle.
That's more interesting to me than me. Like, ah, you're strong. And it's like,
well obviously that's why you're fight with each other. Not going to lie. My.
Least favorite, like enemy fight trope is like the,
the guy in the sidelines explaining everything while it's happening.
To be fair that that's either hit or miss.
Cause the only like one yeah like, like it's,
it's either Speedwagon or it's basically. It's like, it's like,
I dunno how this person yeah.
Is able to like explain every like physics movement as this guy's doing
a one-inch punch. Right? It's like, it's like, what is the timeframe?
How was that happening? Then? There's like Bucky, which is just like, you,
you have an e-sports commentator,
just like explaining every detail and technique and the bags.
I love that, man. I love it. That's the thing. Right? It's like,
if it's like Joe, Joe, Bucky, where it's,
it's it's gone to the point where it's so unrealistic that it just becomes
ridiculous. Exactly. I like that. I hate it when they,
Brian make it as if it's happening in real time. And it's like,
don't kid yourself guys. Like, isn't it.
Like you'd have to be like rap God in order to like commentate over it.
That quickly as it's happening. Yes.
Sometimes you just hear a piece of dialogue in the time it takes us for like one
punch to get thrown. A punch is just like a millisecond. Right.
And they have this five minute dialogue in the middle of their head in between
this punch getting thrown multi page, like right.
It's like where's the punch cards.
No, I'm just like, is time dilation?
Just a thing when the anime characters get punished.
So something like Einstein's rolling in his grave right now. When, when,
whenever a punch gets thrown, man.
The Monga is that where like someone gets stabbed and then like the light,
but you fell in my trap and it's like, how many,
how many times have you practiced this?
Where you just been like stabbed a punch? And this was like potty old plan.
Like, this is just like too, it happened so often.
Or like sometimes they'll get like a fatal wound and they'll immediately like
heal it. And it's like, what? Yeah. But then again.
Right. It's like that,
that kind of goes back into the whole thing of like how ridiculous it is as
well. Right? Like Bucky does that. So often where it's like,
you should be dead after one punch,
but you've somehow managed to survive like 10 punches of stab wound and like
three gunshots. And you're still able to like form a dialogue. Well,
I feel like Baki is just like one side of the extreme where it's so extreme that
you can't take it seriously anymore. But I mean,
I mean a lot of anime flights on that, I like anime trips, like animate.
It's just normalized getting punched and coughing up blood.
Whereas in real life you're internally hemorrhaging and
you're probably going to die. If you internally hemorrhage,
let's be honest if you cough of blood, bro,
not going to be good. If you smash your head through a concrete wall,
which is apparently normal than anime, then you've got a concussion, you know,
or just a splattered head, no head. Exactly.
I want to realistic like toe stubbing seen.
And that what I want. That's what I want to experience.
I mean niche-y joke.
Yeah. Probably toast.
Dubbing is like the closest I get to a real life animation. Right?
I want someone to just animate someone's stubbing their toe.
And that it's just like immediate, like a joke slightly like cough up blood.
And they're like.
Like Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, boy probably did some cause like in real life,
I don't know what it is about stubbing your toe. Like you stop your toe.
And it's one of the few injuries you get where you do it and you know,
the pain is coming.
But for some reason there is a pain delay between you'd stubbing,
your toe and the immense pain.
You're about to feel like if there was a time for a real life,
anime flashback it's in that delayed pain delay, man.
Now, if you were an animated character,
you would realize that you can synchronize your energy to counter the below
incoming.
Come on. You can stop the nervous system from delivering it to your brain.
Yeah. That's that's the closest you get to a enemy injury or whatever.